[Music]
i don't think they even have things
right or a big plan or how they want to
do things
but it's going to affect our kids it's
going to affect their future
some parents sharing their concerns
tonight after a unanimous decision from
the ccsd board of trustees
to start the school year entirely online
now this came just weeks after trustees
passed an initial plan that offered
options of full-time distance learning
and splitting the week at home
and at school well thanks for joining us
at 11 but now it's official clark county
students will be
only doing at-home learning for the
beginning of the school year
thanks for being here i'm denise feldas
and i'm brian loftis tonight's big
decision came during an hours-long
special meeting
between those trustees superintendent
jarrah
and other district leaders
and of course it doesn't come without
some challenges 8 news now reporter orco
mana is here now to explain
orco denise and brian the board of
trustees had a difficult task tonight
but say safety was the deciding factor
for keeping kids at home
there are still concerns about parents
finding child care and students having
enough
strong enough curriculum but the main
focus tonight was on the actual
technology
i don't think the school district is
listening to us
parents passionately voiced their
anxiety over distance education the
clark county school district board of
trustees
voting unanimously tuesday for all
students to begin the upcoming school
year
with at-home learning but it's going to
affect our kids laura leon's daughter is
a high school senior but a previous
brain injury makes online classes hard
i'm really concerned that she's not
going to do well this time and
it's going to affect her because this is
her most important year i don't think
they really have a plan
sarah george's daughter has speech and
development issues she's worried the
individual educational program for her
kindergartner will be ineffective
it's obviously not the same as her being
in a classroom environment
with the teachers for hours you know
where they're teaching her how to
advocate for herself many trustees also
bringing up the issue of inequity when
it comes to students with no internet
access
those that don't are going to slip
down a slippery slope that
is very hard to come back from the
district says they're working with cox
communications to give qualifying
low-income families a discounted rate
and there's more to the plan
we are going to purchase hot spots as
well so
we're going to do this both ways we're
going to try to get broadband
connectivity
through cable connection and then do hot
spots as well
the district says they're working with
cox communications to give qualifying
low-income families a discounted rate
and there's more to the plan
we don't have the chromebooks we don't
have the internet hookup
but we don't need to have people
die and somebody's going to
die still parents are not confident with
what comes next i don't think they even
have things right or a big plan or how
they want to do things
but it's going to affect their kids
trustees made two
other key decisions tonight first they
approved a hybrid teleworking model for
staff
for their professional development days
and second the board also voted to have
traditional
year-long courses with school discretion
for high schools
but semester-based courses for middle
schools the board will also receive
updates every 30 days
on covet 19 trends in nevada to guide
any changes